[Musique]
pongé mère raconte une belle histoire
petit roger je vais te raconter la plus
belle de toute l'histoire de france
[Musique]
m
rio au visage de l'histoire toi ton
esprit sommes en colère
ce concours des grimoires à en oublie
des secrets clio opus de l'histoire
chercheurs
[Musique]
et la fortune des éditeurs
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et rien bois de 9 watts en off line of
nenov buse qui s'amusent à nous ruse
quand on fume idées fusent puis infuse
se diffuse enfin suzanne jamais c'est
très beau de pièces les mr amusé ce soir
une seule lui nous intéresse il sait et
ça n'est pas le trr à sa de bab el melh
peau mais ne se promène chérie ça n'est
pas tarie elle est alité dénonçait clio
ironie de l'histoire à pio inspire nous
pendant une heure de 20h35 à 21h35 entre
les informations et les brigades du
tigre un surcoût fille aux clio les
femmes en général ne nous ont apporté
que des histoires roi clio importe nous
l'histoire avec un grand h
h comme que oui h comme à cheval
l'histoire qui nous permet de répondre
d'un seul coup sans hésiter à waterloo
morne plaine très bien très bien
marignan permanente 14 heures en 24
heures rien 14 112 naissance de jeanne
d'arc tu as tort sur un chan d'arc avait
8 ans c'est ça l'histoire et nourrissant
travaux sur les maudits rois fainéants
nous avions apporté quelques
distinctions flatteuse murmure feutre
églises uniates apporte également
l'admiration et
l'estiment que des historiens de notre
beau pays hexagonal voulu répondre votre
soif de culture par l'eau des halles
terrain tu es que notre savoir et cette
fois ci nos investigations historique
prendront naissance à la renaissance la
fraise à louis xiii le via un hack à
ravaillac fois ci les z'heureux rois
z'henri avec un 10 37 parties
[Musique]
les trois ministres en soit merci de
science parvenir
n'est ce pas là
300 lits ne sont pas morts dans le riz
mais ça n'a pas d'importance
[Musique]
les valeureux
moi j'hésite
il faut les voir et nous avons des
banques
suivent les heureux
il plaisanté
ouah
vient le 3 mai cannes
[Applaudissements]
rois z'henri rois z'henri c'est vite dit
car si nous visitons la galerie de
tableaux des rois qui ont régné sur la
france à cette époque
nous voyons en un françois 1er 10 alors
d'ordre en deux ans rideuses duc
d'auteuil et de vincennes ensuite
charles nov 10 le petit henri iii henri
iv la poule au pot secours à bas coût
low cost donc très peu d'henri il faut
exclure
henri 8 roi d'angleterre est veuf à la
mode qui n'a jamais renier malgré son
vif désir sur notre beau pays de france
et henri de guise qui fait souvent
considérée comme vice roi n'est jamais
comme roy est beaucoup plus tard le
comte de chambord henry 5 qui lui n'a
pas régné du tout mais moi j'ai renier
monsieur moi j'ai renier moi monsieur
qu'est ce que vous faites là
non monsieur vous avez parlé les rois
z'henri sua rois z'henri lequel qu'est
ce que je fais bien mon métier je suis
rap français henri promu hamel henry
premier lagacé c'est pourtant à henri
premier puisqu'il ya eu un arrêt de ben
oui il faut bien qu'ils aient un premier
sont 21 secondes on n'y pense jamais ans
et provient il s'en passe pas - ça ma
femme me le dit toujours en riz thé
terme ans rita termes littéraires et
vous l'êtes beaucoup oui oui vous êtes
d'herbe
l'important vous êtes drôle non si on me
dit non je pourrais vous dire si terne
mais n'a pas dit non je peux pas dire si
c'est ce qu'on avait prévu y abondent
ja dites moi j'en reprends là où on
avait dit et vous avez vécu longtemps
j'aimais tu 2008 1060 pas beaucoup ça
fait cinquante deux ans quand même pour
les petits et vous faites à quelle
époque a qu'à l'époque je suis un cap et
ciani je suis le fils à robert robert le
pieux ah oui on l'appelait ainsi parce
qu'il était très croyant non non on
croyait passé on l'appelait le pieux
parce qu'il dormait beaucoup et vous
avez fait la guerre
oui bah faut bien oui même si je n'étais
pas doué pour c'est d'abord j'ai j'ai
horreur du change peut pas avoir le sang
alors j'évite est la guerre et vous
essayer à force d'éviter en a l'air de
fuir
vous connaissez les autres et son salon
les autres et en profitait à barbara
quelle connerie la guerre et vous avez
pas beaucoup de victoires alors que des
dérouillées ensemble d'aidés faites vos
jeux le pire des pâtes et des pattes
ailées 30 vous pouvez passeur d'ions de
leurs concurrentes escrime amis comme
patins comme pas terrible mais une
petite taille et vous demandez aussi que
vous avez eu une mort glorieuse pas du
tout minable lamentable
un coup de sang moi j'aime pas ça cour
des comptes bien sûr ça devait arriver
mais votre fils alors minable fini vos
premiers en finale
une famille noble alors il a pris une
pente et à cassel alors décidément cette
famille a oui c'est la vie et vous
l'avais gardé aucune rancune pour tous
épatés on n'est pas un chien citerne
citerne d'ailleurs je n'ai pas compris
mais la pâte et de chasse est donc
vous non plus ah bon moi je voulais vous
dire que c'était très drôle mais enfin
vous voyez pas pourquoi j'ai pris une
pâte et de chiens non bon et tout à
l'heure quand citerne on commence bien
reste à vous ah bon c'est vrai alors dit
aux six mètres qu'on répète en raison de
la grève d'une certaine partie du texte
gisèle autres je m'étais je m'étais
images oui je vais participer à cette
galerie est un xian henry je suis henri
chenot vous ne pouvez pas rester là à
temps et par mettez-vous là si vous
voulez ah mais je ne peux pas vous
mettre dans un cadre bah vous êtes comme
ma famille où elle peut pas m'encadrer
voilà un truc là la femme peut pas
encadrer
on voyait pas non plus pas tel chien non
plus si terme non plus on comptait là
dessus ça faisait 3 effet sa furia dit
moi je ne peux pas vous garder dans un
cadre parce que tous les personnages qui
sont la route humeur passé glorieux
l'abri tandis que mme achoui terne mais
non mais non s'ils terminent au bond et
mais écoutez reste hélas pas le cul
voyez pas le pieux voyez pas le pieux je
vous le téléphonerait si ça marche lundi
un bon alors voyez vous tous ces
personnages sont donc réunies et vous
vous restez dans ce coin là tranquille
réunis et pourquoi parce qu'ils ont tous
un point commun
regardez les bien attentivement les uns
après les autres tous ces personnages
ont un point commun parce qu'ils ont une
belle
ils ont tous une belle
regardez-bien barbe très jolie barbe et
ses barbes
vous les retrouverez sur françois 1er
sur henry 2 sur charles à 9 sur henri
iii sur henri iv tous une barbe louis
xiii et son fils un soupçon et louis xiv
plus de barbe du tout il faudra ton
napoléon iii et surtout le président
fallières pour voir une barbe régné sur
la france
trois cent soixante-cinq ans sans barbe
ou presque et c'est là notre propos vous
faire revivre ses 130 ans de règne du
poil de france ma première et de l'essor
à feu louis xiii
mais comment tout cela s'est il passé et
bien voici
c'était en 15 100 ou presque vous
n'étiez pas démérité
par une belle matinée d'hiver dans les
fossés du louvre des jeunes gens de la
cour de france s'amuse aujourd'hui il y
avait là ambroise marins de mon cher
florence gil aventure rue bonnivet le
bien aimé chabot sans potel la marque
sont caulaincourt bourbon un grand sac
qui surtout françois d'angoulême
je voulais c'est moi
ces beaux jeunes jouent se livraient
alors jeu innocent quand soudain la
neige se mit à tomber la neige a mis à
la tâche
la dette brute de colomb hôpital de gaza
vit soudain tous ces jeunes gens sont
pris d'une envie irrésistible dans mes
enfants dans mes enfants en vie
résistible de jouer aux boules de neige
vous serez pour peu qu'on aime et
bientôt c'est la joie c'est là c'est
l'âge c'est l'âge
cette norme est maintenant parce que
j'ai les médocs au bâton je suis enrhumé
et bientôt ce jeu si abusant enfin si on
veut va tourner au drame
maubeuge
que s'est il passé je sais qu'il de
passer oui on a un rôle historique
voilà des mois qui dit que s'est il
passé non je suis désolé messieurs mais
république j'en ai qu une mère pour les
je suis désolé j'ai le livre je suis un
ami des auteurs je déjeune parfois le
dimanche à l'ego il me donnait cette
réplique j'y tiens abattus les connais
bien ils sont un peu paresseux quand
même son charisme il justement il n'en
est qu'une réplique ils me l'ont donné
avant mais enfin à l'occasion des fêtes
de fin d'année je vous laisse cette
réplique mais on est là comme il serait
alors j'achète alors attendez m'étais
bien qu'innovant prouver le temps que
ses études au passé a bien atteint mais
je sais rien moi non plus
la de nous ou s'est avisé du brasero que
moi six mois qui a pris à disons non la
glisser dans une boule de neige au sol
et l'a jetée sur françois noblet face à
la fouine roi louis xii n'a pas
d'héritier mâle françois sera seul
prétendant pour senna jaloux qui
affaiblit mairie qui vais vous le dire
mais qui plus est les cloches de notre
dame se dire tu as eu des personnes
monsieur jamais non le fautif a même
monsieur michelet professeur au collège
de france
pas même notre ami jacques chazot qui
pourtant c'est tout ce qui se passe dans
park
[Rires]
pendant ce temps françois d'angoulême
chercher de consolation auprès de sa
mère louise de savoie
séparez les blancs des jaunes vient
battre avec eux pu ajouter les parfums
l'a fait qu un petit frère les blancs
bien battus de la farine pour être le
tout dans un moule bien vrai mettre à
four moyen plus chaud mais mon savoir le
nom savoir d'étoilés soit tranquille
juste un gâteau un gâteau deux à
gatineau le nom laisse tomber maman
laisse tomber j'ai besoin de ta
sollicitude maternelle
mais si je laisse tomber des blancs vont
retomber ban espère tomber mais oui
c'est tombé maman j'ai mal ça me brûle
encore un grand qui t'a battu non ça me
brûle j'ai reçu une boule de magie
monsieur brute de neige et à brûle toi
tu as encore dit il faut dire que
françois d'angoulême était né à cognac
en 14 100 94
si ça me brûle maman sa voix ça me brûle
et les voyous qui t'as fait ça écoute
chez celles qui l'ont bien qu'ils ont
dans une boule mais j'en sais rien
épicycle je le saurai excusez moi madame
mais je le jeu l'est déjà dit personne
ne le saura jamais viactive écoutez
madame g livre alors je peux pas me
tromper vérifier vous même
ah bon et ben non savoir mon bobo royal
en pire
je vais chercher un médecin conventionné
ça risque d'être long c'est ma passion
mon françois regarde la télé oui maman
[Musique]
c'est le nez alors nous donne envie
parce que jean pose quelle est votre
opinion
quelle est votre opinion docteur docteur
merci cette phrase peut vous paraître
bizarre et pas mal d'autres choses mais
ce sont là les les inconvénients et les
avantages directs des spas cette phrase
disait je vous à paraître bizarre avoue
assurés sociaux du 20e siècle mais il
faut vous dire qu'à cette époque les
chirurgiens étaient des barbiers en
somme des coiffeurs et que cela devait
durer jusqu'au xviiie siècle
souvenez-vous figaro la marelle vie
rang mais méritée pour la barre
bon alors écoutez après examen
approfondi du patient voici mon
ordonnance un poème à à la morale n'est
ce pas séchage au peg mexique à des
bombes à cheval en forêt pour la prime
est sûre alors pour l'investir juste une
fatigue pas mal hydra top mais pas plus
est ce qu'il y aura une cicatrice
atteint 6,6 il y aura maintenant mon
beau visage d'angoumois balafré françois
ça fait homme
ça fait au même et ça s'appelait en
changement pour jouer au bon moment
écoutez moi je ne peux rien pour vous
mon bon monsieur
la chirurgie esthétique n'est pas encore
inventé et ambroise paré 9 10 ans et
passera dernier mot d'acteurs non non
mais là mon dernier mot c'est santé qu
ils ont augmenté de 14% à rabat
merci madame beau alors voulait plus
besoin de moi j'peux bouclé
nous savons que vous êtes libre docteur
au vous êtes clip suit si vous êtes plus
vous êtes libre tu pas g7 gémir à
l'épouvantail beau bazar bizarre -o
j'ai même plus le temps de me faire un
brushing maman comme quand j'étais petit
je suis pas là fait c'est affreux je
suis défiguré il faut faire quelque
chose
oui mais quoi cherchons a fait quelque
chose ça y est tu as trop d'humains j'ai
oublié ma feuille de sécurité sociale
aux la barbe la barbe non labarde
l'appartement la barque la part merci je
vous remercie ça va déjà beaucoup mieux
la barbe quelle bonne idée quelle bonne
idée venait venait d'être trouvé
françois c'était ça la solution pour
masquer sa blessure
la barbe cette mode qui allait régner
sur les hommes de france pendant plus de
100 ans la barbe qui allait inspirer les
auteurs de chansons populaires c'est moi
qui suis la femme à barbe connaissez ça
ou encore l'automne et parlez-moi de
menteuse appris à laisser celle là je
prenais la note aaa comme chez le
coiffeur à je me tiens tu te tiens par
la barbichette ce que laissait pas le
premier de nous deux il rira aura une
[ __ ]
laborde la bam qui allait lui faire
obtenir à ce beau françois le plus gros
succès lorsqu'il se présenta après
plusieurs semaines d'absence à la cour
de france maintenant doté d'un longuet
tournée triomphale en aunis et saintonge
et pour son retour la cour
nous avons le plaisir et l'honneur de
vous présenter françois d'angoulême
franck l'afrique ce que vous en pensez
croyez moi j'ai l'habitude fait un
succès
et quel succès car bientôt tout le monde
vous le tvt
france soir d'abord les seigneurs puis
les officiers et enfin les bidasses tout
le monde portait la barbe ce qui donnait
un aspect curieux au bal de la cour
[Musique]
e
oh
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma chère amie tout le monde me félicite
chaleureusement pour ma part il n'y a
que vous qui n'avez encore rien dit je
brûle de connaître votre opinion mais
qui est cette femme
eh bien vous le saurez en écoutant
attentivement ce qu'elle va vous dire je
m'appelle croûte de france je suis
charmante hydre assez intelligente et
cultivée
je suis la fille du roi de france louis
xii il épouse de françois d'angoulême
ici présents dont ceux ci follement
éprise claudie les yeux dans les yeux
même rêver ou poilu autant car à berne
mais françois vous êtes mon mari sorgues
l'est mon devoir est de les aimer que ce
que le même claude françois laurent soir
lotois reçoit claude françois arrêter la
musique votre bon roi louis xii est au
plus mal
comment et au plumard est au plus mal
on fait alors il est en train de crever
le canon la cua coriace et lorient lt
loi maman tu continues tu es le roi
puisqu'il meurt sans héritier mâle à
ceux pourtant wolf
c'est une bonne nouvelle
le roi va mieux racontant la soirée non
[Rires]
mes amis il ya du mieux
juste un peu de sa tombe merci ma
mélodie n'ont pas émoussé françois mon
bonheur
60e à vous êtes généreux boom géant et
c'est une grosse fatigue pourquoi j'ai
décidé de radio ni jour pour moi
mais la nouvelle terreur comme la charge
des rois d'angleterre et s'appelle marie
dionne
c'est marie dior aux familles des gens
qui sont des jambons
pour important venez jaune elle est
belle elle a tout ce qu'il faut pour
animer mon ardeur héritiers
alors c'est psychique non cb on va mener
en attendant je vais me reposer pour
mais je ne fais pas de latin au labrador
à vue le mari de moi nous ne vîmes
poèmes ou bien que nous ne puissions pas
dit qu'il fut pillée votre mari à hilla
et des français le mois au louis xii
c'est mon ongle et où vous êtes marié
dior c'est ça oui mais vous vous êtes
françois d'angola oui oui mesdemoiselles
releveur justin alors vous attend oui
bataille les charmants fait à ces
changements
et oui les charmants et son opinion n'a
pas changé quand quelques jours plus
tard elle réussit elle réussi à
l'attirer chez elle dans sa chambre
c'est glissant du monde
c'est bien de faire le ménage c'est
charmant oui ces jeunes et j'ai trop
cirer ses charmants moi c'est bien tenez
votre mari n'est pas la bonne alors les
dames à deux étages plus bas
alors il est pas gênant votre mental
voilà voilà voilà
et des domestiques et ils sont partis
pour congés payés ils sont partis pour
se reposer il faut sauver les petites
choses à 8 6 et 7 trois buts oui il faut
un charme au charbon bye bye baby genou
grignols guignols non rigole jean
brignole je suis un ami qui vous veut du
bien
je voulais lâche vous empêcher de
commettre une erreur
vous êtes tombés dans un piège françois
leroy ne peut pas lui faire des enfants
mais vous si bien que je pus oui c'est
certain je vous connais et sept enfants
elle prétendre à kiel et du roi rêver
alors pour vous adieu la couronne ce
n'est pas pour mon charme que m'a tiré
ici mon annif aimons oléron fait boire
votre avis aulas qui s'est pas à mauléon
ça c'est super c'est pas un bon mot
laisse vous permettez à tour de france 3
corse est intacte tu es un tarte
nous avons de faire plaisir mais non
mais non mais non petit savon du plaisir
et nous est très beau mais je suis pas
bon je vous assure que vous êtes non non
j'en ai grandi c'est bon si vous suis
pas bon je me sens non vous exagérez
m'écouter convaincant l'a quand même
fait 7 beaufort le connais je dois
sortir avec mon ami oui j'ai une séance
avec guignol grignols au revoir madame 1
le roi louis xii ne sut jamais rien de
cette aventure
c'est pourquoi le 1er janvier une année
qui commençait mal pour lui
il mourut fatigué mais content on se
lève le doigt sur le bobo 1
voilà mes marie d'york maman dans la pas
si facilement l'idée de régner sur la
france
je suis enceinte ça se voit
oui tout enfant descendance ne pas lui
donner un meilleur affichage messieurs
vous permettez voilà le fils de louis
xii retourner en angleterre dans l'ès go
home et la saint louis les têtes
le roi ne pense aux poussins alors moi
c'est moi because the valley
[Applaudissements]
mon chapeau mon chapeau et maintenant ça
on est ici au louvre tapissier
décorateur menuiserie s'ils changent moi
tous ces modes kotick c'est laid c'est
lourd c'est mme ashton tu es moche tout
ça et puis alors ses plans je sors des
tréteaux pour manger c'est comment oates
a un amant témoin la table avec des
pieds et pour dormir
une paria sur des chats les noms avant
témoin le lie à que nous ils atténuent
le lien que nous c'est le lie à colonnes
colosse à vrai dire que nous et que nous
se réunir comme et d'avoir filer sa
quenouille c'est vrai peut dire fils et
holly shakoor herbe dont je vais un
oreiller
je voudrais années de route avec des
plumes mais ça n'existe pas mais bien
avant télé n'en voudra un meuble un mot
avec des petits tiroirs mon métier
secret puis que sa ferme à clé on met
des secrets et sa femme a dit on appelle
ça un s'écrie-t-elle secrétaire vous l'a
inventé et puis un homme le plus
pratique plus long pour étaler les
vêtements commodément comme ça un meuble
longue mais je suis vraiment commun je
serais vraiment commode la commerz vous
me vanter la commode mais ce pas et
lorsque c'est pratique ça c'est pratique
ça devant une télé le soir c'est
pratique ça non je veux un siège
confortable
c'est ce confortable qu'un dossier
inclinable et un siège pivotant je veux
parler de ma mère ou ma tata je me parle
avec ma femme on a fait un tabac et que
je caquette jeu caquette jeu qui
inquiète le cac est on appelle ça un cac
thouars cas que toi tu en voilà ça c'est
mon style c'est le style renaissance
vous
ça c'est du maire mais en italie
la guerre va reprendre françois à la
tête de ses troupes à traverser les
alpes comme un vulgaire hannibal mais
cette fois-ci sant éléphant et se
retrouve à marignan exactement entre
pinasco et mirabel là ils vont en
découdre avec maximilien sforza
il a dans son camp bayard la pallice
sans malice galliot de génolhac avec ses
72 canaux
trente mille hommes dix mille cavaliers
et en prime son beau frère un peu âgés
pour la guerre le duc d'alençon
nous sommes ne l'oublié pas le 13 août
15 115 mais en europe c'est bonjour
monsieur de la palisse vous avez grossi
tourner vos jumelles aaa dit pas si le g
comme vous me l'avez demandé
offert 600 mille étudiants aux suisses
qui se battent pour les italiens
à condition qu'il quitte le champ de
bataille on reste qu'ils acceptent à ben
série l'accepterons n'est ce pas s'il ne
refuse pas on va ce qui risque d'être
refusée là ils risquent de leur refuser
s'ils n'acceptent pas ces seules excuses
accès bas ils acceptent ce qui est fait
s'il accepte c'est qu'ils ne refuseront
pas voilà le problème n'est pas là en ce
moment ils n'hésitent ils désirent aux
eaux où j'ai peur qu'il ne soit trop
tard qu'on en perd à nos parts vous
bayard non je crains qu'il ne soit trop
tard
rsa reproche brava ya un reproche à
jamais si vous êtes prêt raillard oui je
vous dirais bataille de marion on peut
commencer
[Musique]
mais c'est la vaillance et commencer à
badens mais si finement avec difficile
très difficile
ça va être coton
[Musique]
le bic avance on recule te faire plaisir
piqué au vif
l'accord est important plus de certains
pays et en tirant si nous continuons à
ne pas renier nous allons finir par
perdre et il faudra employer la force
française et la fourrière est déjà pris
quatre ans chez ge est un choix langlois
ne comprend pas le français aux
espagnols
[Musique]
arch
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel combat c'est sa faute de carburant
une sonnerie chez bayard si aussi élevé
voilà j'ai rétabli la situation et à 11
heures juste avant l'apéritif tout était
fini nous c'était 36 rue des alouettes
n'ont par le studio bataille à ces à
marignane mario joly et marivaux je me
trompais 1514 vous comptez bien il se
pourrait qu'on soigne en cette année je
retiens de jeu 1915 à mayol face au
marignan tous les écoliers s'en
souviennent marignan 15 sans gaz mais il
reste un souvenir visible cette bataille
car dans l'euphorie de la victoire
et pour fêter ses 21 ans françois
premier décide de s'offrir un petit
cadeau mais alors quel cadeau quatre
mille écus d'or
bonjour monsieur le plein aujourd'hui à
l'acheteur asseyez-vous deux ans oui
charlie wi là vous êtes tombé sur un os
c'est que monsieur léonard ainsi si si
si si si si vaste et si c'est ça mon
tonton a beaucoup parlé de vous avant
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent un vous le
connaissez roi de france roi de france
engagée du le connaîtra journée toulouse
angers dulko nette hausse et parce que
12 12
il m'a les deux années le potable au
welsh prend un peu de temps en temps de
neige fait ce matin j'ai fait ça c'est
pas mal ça pitch est simple un brel
c'est très joli assez vive ans et vivant
ça c'est ça c'est du vivant comme passé
très près donc pas dire ses palais ses
palais ses palais c'est nourrissant si c
est bien c track 10 est passé de la
peinture léché mais l'esprit est
cafouillé là dedans je dois avoir deux
trois saloperies l'auto l'écart garder
un tube au chêne pop pour vous je
continue mon travail je fais comme si
j'étais chez moi là je suis en train de
faire un truc tu as créé des inventaires
à si ça marche ça fera du ruban
inventeur c'est beaucoup dire je suis
bricoleur bricoleur tenez par exemple
j'ai fait ça pour ça marchera jamais
très bien ça correspond pas au nom fait
ça aussi ça sert à rien mais ça fait de
l'effet là ça fait de l'effet l'assassin
presse papier précise un presse purée on
sait pas précise nous nous surprenons
puis alors la machine à vapeur c'est moi
s'il vous plaît la chambre obscure
pendant la photo c'est encore moi je
suis un peu médecins aussi c'est moi qui
ai trouvé la circulation sanguine
ahahah le scaphandre c'est moi le temps
que c'est encore moins si vous rêvez
la mitrailleuse porterait sur le temps
c'est encore moi j'aurais bien voulu
trouver le vernis qui colle mais enfin
ça et j'ai questionné trouvait encore en
voyage trouve plus voilà à voilà la
machine volante et pourtant ça fait du
bruit ça la concorde est encore à bâle
au parachute levallois chez vous pour
sauter de la machine volante les lycées
mois le vaccin contre la rage c'est vous
oh non faut pas charrier ce poste vous
en avez des sites et des idées doit pas
pas mon jour
n'hésitez une jambe décembre j'en ai
mire elles sont l'attentât qu'est ce
profil vous pèse encore dans mon cerveau
s'y bousculent comme dans métro j'en ai
mis mimi mymyme il soit trop des sites
et jean paul minn
dans ta
pour les jours l encourager plus place
elle songé à l'e3 c'est la vérité ma foi
j'ai le crâne comme craint trop petit
pour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bush anti âge est repéré deux tableaux
sunna et l'autre là mais j'hésite mieux
si je me sens à ben ça c'est un saint
jean baptiste aux yeux doux ça vaut
trois mille écus d'or
enfin ça fait cher à bénédicte est c'est
fait à la main alors et celui ci à ça
c'est le portrait de la señora del
giocondo la joconde à quatre mille écus
d'or est plus cher et plus petit clown
oui mais attention j'ai eu des frais un
maintien pendant qu'elle posait il
fallait des des chanteurs des musiciens
des comics en serait et souriait jamais
parce que là il est charmant franchement
regardez cette bonté dans le regard
cette indulgence moi j'aime me faire
passer pour celui-là je les ratés n'ont
cessé la première esquisse abrégé
l'autre la pensée très bien samedi soir
mais voilà avec le code et vous dis je
l'achète
mais les conditions n'étaient menés que
moi en france abbas a à bassa je veux
bien parce que j'aime mieux être le
premier en france que le second d'italie
mais qui sait le premier en italie
protégez-vous mon pauvre monsieur nickel
ange erc nick loges monsieur droit des
comptes
moi je veux pas être le poulidor de
michel-ange à la normale au milieu des
abricotiers un truc en bois c'est un
instrument de musique c'est un sorte de
viol un peu longue
une vielle non une gueule long crimes
violents
comment venir une fiole long
j'appellerais ça violon c'est pas mal le
sens le long des viols longue
alors oui c'est accorder de quinton
quinte mais pas trop près pour pas que
ça colle aucun s'est très bien passé de
viser 200 lequel on sait très bien et
vous enjouer a pas du tout c'est
absolument prendre par contre ivry
gitlis haut et lui il a inventé la
chemin là je n'ai pas rester sans cesse
à ses droits c'est pas droit comme ça
ses droits ses droits ça va ça vous
plaît pour moi tu sais la peinture
moderne et vous clos où vous avez l'air
déçu j'avoue que j'espérais que vous me
rapportez riez autre source de votre
voyage en italie
mais quoi dans le par exemple je ne sais
pas un petit pull à sac des escarpins
dorés mais j'ai rapporté beaucoup mieux
rendez-vous leur est des plus exotiques
d'un jardin de peace
ce sont des prunes mais pas n'importe
quel corps humain sont vertes aux eaux
sont douces et délicieuse
rafraîchissante
elles sont comme vous elles sont
merveilleuses on les appellera les rênes
clos en france soit vous êtes
merveilleux ils ont toujours flatté les
hommes abusés passe à peu près une but
d'abuser de mabuse et n'abusez pas de ça
qu'est ce qu'elle m'aime claude françois
loos françois hollande françois claude
françois
on a dit c'est une chanson par personne
n'y a pas de raison de faire appel à une
face à causant la mort et de paris
s'offre un tour chacun comme à la boxe
on continue bas historique à ce moment
là que trois soirs ça l'était tout à
l'heure pas maintenant mais françois 1er
avait des soucis d'ordre politique et
diplomatique
il voulait montrer aux espagnols
menaçant que son cousin le roi
d'angleterre henry 8 était son meilleur
ami tu ne t'es pas tout à fait la vérité
d'ailleurs il voulait aussi donné henry
8 l'impression que la france était un
pays riche et sera est un allié puissant
pour l'angleterre ce qui n'était pas
vrai du tout henri vite ayant à peu près
les mêmes soucis on décida donc de se
rencontrer dans le nord de la france les
anglais s'installèrent à guise et les
français a harsh les camps était
somptueux chacun voulait épater l'autre
et c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que l'on a
appelé cette entrevue historique l'autre
vue du camp du drap d'or
[Musique]
m
à voir on ne peut pas
voilà ce qu'il y a
k
elle
le plus là
m
là bas
oh
[Musique]
et
ce chagrin
[Musique]
ça fait plaisir de se retrouver entre
amis au cet accent britannique je ne me
fera jamais votre dame n'est pas là nous
non la reine claude un peu ses
confitures et là vous elle a perdu la
tête
alors la sémec petit camping caravaning
on se croirait chez tri ghana je suis
d'avis que 300 seigneur il y a quatre
mille gentilshommes et géo geo
geostationary avait aussi 400 tentes
questeur au fait je m'excuse émana
manquait une à leur propriété en direct
pensez vous resterez vous piquer mon
client continue et de mon côté c'est pas
mal non plus 300 tentes place et de 20
pieds en vacquiers des pieds en anglais
des fuites fit foot sont peut-être pas
en de la dore mais c'est de la belle
toile blanche quand même oui
mylène mylène c'est une bonne qualité et
c'est de la bonne qualité n'est pas la
seule c'est simplement à six il faille
ne sais pas le nombre
et là j'ai aussi un palais en bois en
2000 pieds de côté on dire a déclaré aux
deux 47 âge une tête anglaise ça fait
dix pieds une téte anglais ça fait 6
pieds et vous êtes des mille pattes vous
c'est de l'humour français ça c'est pas
bien fin j'ai aussi une buvette qu'on
sorte de bar for the dreams on the rocks
l'accent rocailleux des anglais ça fait
rurales et dans ce bar il ya trois
fontaines une pause le vin une pour
l'eau et une poly peau grasse ah si je
comprends bien on a lutté son ami en
chaque pile tu l'as des bouffées cet
anoblissement pas seulement si on
commençait par les vins et spiritueux
commençons par les spiritueux sera
spirituel ou ruiz 1 à bienne et n est qu
un soldat il maintient premier rang
consommation d'alcool match nul sujet
était détaché auprès de vous par le
cardinal ou le sait pour vous pouvez
vous causez cause d'un fléau fléau que
d'autres quelques doutes quelques dates
auxquelles qu'on attache pas assez
d'importance il peut s'agir de dire
l'alcoolisme
la culture c'est pas du tout quand vous
allez au café vous buvez america 6 une
finale roma kirsch
mais vous vous suicider on dit que
l'alcool c'est de l'eau-de-vie gros chez
l'homme jésus l'occasion plusieurs fois
de voir le cardinal roule c'est l'andra
cobayes savez ce que c'est qu'un cobaye
sèche c'est un petit lapin et lui 18
juil inocule
juin' aucune once est d'origine ont
jamais fait inoculer un peu d'alcool de
betteraves comme dtn enfin du phoque
ducale en deux qu'est ce qu'il vient de
cobaye d'abord il s'est plutôt content
ni gambader fait beau fait la you come
into my enfin va bien tout d'un coup
plus bonhomme tout le cobaye les morts
l'alcool tue révolte si vous prenez un
buveur je tente pas du vrai alcoolique
le missile non sens mais 300 grandes
paroles d'un citron 454 kg en six mois
j'ai compté vous me direz j'ai pas du
gros kg c'est lui qui le gagnent liquide
mais quand même comme un c + 1 m6 c'est
une époque j'ai commencé comme ascétique
estrosi plus tard les enfants de ce
monsieur
il est prouvé en france christique sur
neuf morts ba ba de tata y en a un qui
tu es par l'alcoolisme s'envolent sans
compter ce qui dépasse par jour ce
monsieur moi je vois tous les matins
j'arrose mot café un rhum sous insuline
celui de rome sans le jury trois roms
180 chine 80 côté vous même sans compter
ce qu'ils voient chez lui à table avec
sa femme ce monsieur moi j'ai ma femme
en fait cela c'est ma femme de ménage
les blanchisseuses à travail dans l'eau
unis faut ni compensation
il y faisait 4 litres à chaque repas si
vous l'êtes solide à 40 ans comme le
jeune de rose aux joues des halles du
guerrier pour défendre le pays tandis
que quand il est dans l'embarras
si vous voulez avoir des économies pour
vous faire plaisir
ne buvez pas d'alcool la culture n'est
pas douteux à d'autres
deuxième ronde duels à l'épée l'anglais
et vainqueur il a voulu croiser le fer
il est le passé le lendemain pas de
chance
un coup de vent et la tante de françois
1er s'écroula avantages matériels
anglais le nom de man encore 4e rang
tournoi henri 8 est encore vainqueur oui
toujours l'enfer d'une allumette m'amuse
iam est légitime pour l'instant
l'avantagé était plutôt aux anglais
comme vous pouvez le constater mais au
tir à l'arc
françois repris du poil de la bête face
au jeu les piqués au vif derniers
matches hélas ce qui fut fatale à henri
car la bretagne en dehors des blondes et
galettes des crêpes à une spécialité la
lutte bretonne
[Musique]
massimo lipper il ya quelques petits
nantais par millions
[Musique]
ils se saluent
kim se divette
[Musique]
il se présente
il citera ils ont
pile poil
oh
[Musique]
le cardinal
revient très bien très
il en perd ses cheveux la bretagne
j'étais très très bonne vous êtes
gallois péter alors mon cousin
s'attendent pas que ça dans mes bras
france dans ses bras françois genoud luz
il croit n'avoir matin défend toi ça
fait mal ça s'appelle un appel à lui en
prit car quelques instants plus tard
quelques instants plus tard quelques
instants pour l'angleterre est à terre
par les tatars et à tort est à l'état
soeur jeudi j'ai glissé c'est tout il
m'a glissé un que l'église et vous avez
glissé et il a glissé vous n'êtes pas
fâché en ligne pour viendrez me voir
écouter
hamon avait pris il faut attendre pour
revoir un souverain britannique en
france il faudra attendre
1855 dans trois cent trente cinq ans on
a le temps de causer bat bat je me sens
pas lui c'est vrai d'accès s'il ya quoi
que ce soit demandé
pour ceux ci vous avez ci avait quoi que
ce soit je sens comme une hésitation et
rhodes
dès l'instant que tu es là tu es nous
fait confiance je suis là voilà on vient
en aide aux familles on a tassé c'est
par un arrêt du peuple et de l'ovaire
les salésiens rêvé d'être vertueux tu ne
rates chaud oui il ya une chose que vous
autres les français vous ne saurez
jamais prendre c'est lorik anglo saxons
[Musique]